welcome everyone to the 2024 January
Meetup start of a new year so thank you
all for being here really looking
forward to this year's lineup of nice
bunch of things we got going going to be
a nice fun year of talks so the very
first thing we always do it's a little
harder nowadays of the economic Outlook
it looks like but if anyone's hiring let
us know is anyone in the room
hiring not anymore man we have like five
six people raise their hands stop laying
off people hire people all right so if
no one's h in in the room if anyone
watching virtually is hiring you can go
to the NY hackr slack and we'll post
that in the chat room in in the YouTube
chat and there's a channel called job
postings you get post jobs there people
can apply for them someone applied just
in the past few days someone put up a
link in the past few days I hope people
applied so if you want a job go to the
job posting section of the NY hackr
slack you don't know where that slack is
go to Nyack r.org there's a link for it
used to be pretty hidden but we made it
less obscure
so for those of you in the room those of
you virtual you're going to be left out
for a moment those of you in the room
the pizza today came from Village Square
pizza I want everyone to take out their
phones those of you who are repeats know
the routine and go to bit. lee/ pizzle
bitly / Pizza pole all lowercase and
there's going to be a five scale a five
point scale for you to rank how you like
this pizza let us know how it is and
then I as you're voting they tell you
the back story it's alleged that this is
the same recipe that is used at prin
Street Pizza which is a really famous
place in fact it's actually the site of
the first ever original famous Rays
right so this is Village Square which is
supposedly a copycat recipe I don't know
I'm not getting into that but hope if
you enjoyed it if you didn't enjoy it go
vote some of you didn't take out your
phones you should be voting looking at
you right I can shame you into voting
right those of you that are watching
from home go to the chat either the
monthly Meetup chat of the slack or of
the YouTube channel and let us know what
you're eating if you're eating pizza let
us know where it's from if you're eating
noodles tell us where it's from if you
have a beverage let us know uh we're all
looking to have you know a fun time
eating together if you can't be here in
person at least hopefully you're
enjoying something far away and actually
I know there's virtual people watching
from down the street I saw some people
sign up who went to NYU and we're at NYU
right now so you know they were you know
if you can't be here you can't be
here another news about another event we
have coming up this year is the 10th
anniversary of the New York R conference
we're really excited it's been 10 years
of this and it's actually the 15th year
of this meet up so we're going to have a
nice big celebration and as part of the
conference it is May 16th through 17th
so May 16th through 17th we send out a a
save the date we have not gone live yet
with ticket sales when we do go live you
could use code NY hackr for 20% discount
and there's also going to be workshops
to be announced very shortly so that's
coming up in just a few months May 16th
through 17th 10th anniversary of nyr
15th anniversary of this Meetup so we're
really excited about this we have a
great lineup coming we have a bunch of
the Old Guard ofthe art community coming
some of the new guard a mixture of
people it's going to be a lot of
fun and for the people attending today
both in the room and virtually we will
draw a name at random to give away a
free ticket to the event and that free
ticket can be used either virtually or
in person as you see
fit speaking of speakers the Meetup
Group needs more speakers all right
every few months sometimes we have this
thing planned 6 months in advance
sometimes we have it planned 3 weeks in
advance right now we're in the 5we in
advance phase so if anyone in this room
hasn't given a talk raise your hand and
say you're going to give a talk oh I saw
it you raise your hand no all right
seriously I won't pressure you if you
want to give a talk if you're a virtual
speaker person you're going to be
passing through New York you want to
give a talk let us know all you have to
do is send me an email slack me find me
on Twitter get in touch of any of us we
are here and eager to have people give
talks that's how this month's speaker I
I asked does anyone have anyone want to
give a talk he emailed me within like
three minutes and said he'll give a talk
so we need more people like that come
give talks don't make me Chase you some
of you have been chasing for a while and
you're you're you're going have to pay
the piper soon all right but anyone
else just let me know when you want to
give a talk all right it's very
easy and that goes you don't want to
give a talk in February by the way we
also have slots in March and April
available uh May is full already believe
it or not but you know that's the way it
works sometimes so after the Meetup
after the talk for the people in the
room sorry folks virtual we are going to
go to the bar and have a few beverages
if you don't drink alcohol have a soda
or a water or whatever just come hang
out with us we have it narrowed down to
two bars Von and the Half Pint and
George is going to pick the winner half
pint we're going to the half pint all
right so after the talk we going go the
half pint if you don't know where it is
you have Google Maps if that doesn't
work you'll follow one of us there okay
okay so lots of exciting things hope
everyone is going to post jobs on the
job Channel hope everyone's enjoying
their food whether in person or
virtually we have the New York R
conference coming up May 16th through
17th and we need speakers and we're
going to the bar sound good everybody
all right well welcome to 2024 hope
everyone has a start to a great New Year
and we're looking forward to a whole
bunch of good meetups so with that I'm
very excited to introduce our speaker
who volunteered to speak right I want
more volunteers uh going to give what
I'm sure is going it's already looking
like to be an exciting talk though you
apparently gave this in October 2023 so
we need a time machine so someone had to
call you out it might as well have been
me so everyone can see it so with that
everyone please welcome
[Applause]
vickram thank you Jared um thank you all
for being here uh you didn't have to
call call me out on that because uh I
knew this uh as soon as I was writing
this and uh I wanted to retain it for
for a reason uh so this talk is based on
a talk that I had given at NYU for a
bunch of students and researchers on um
the Practical side of machine learning
for myself I wanted to know what what
has changed in the slide since I made it
in October 2023 to uh where it is right
now so thank you for calling it out
anyway um so there are three uh quote
unquote phases to this stock or three
portions to this stock the first is uh
some of the thinking traps in machine
learning
uh I'm going to go through a quick
sketch of how commonly machine learning
is thought of and U uh how people uh
argue about it uh Implement them and so
on and so forth um and some of the
thinking traps involved in that the
second part of the talk is essentially
on um how one can use structures and
perspectives to perhaps not fall into
some of those trps and it's not that
those straps are um dangerous quote
unquote it's just that those straps are
avoidable if we put in a little bit of
uh foresight and thought into what
exactly is it that we're building and
the the final part of the talk is um an
example of an engineered solution that
allows us to kind of remediate and look
and have a perspective where one doesn't
um uh one doesn't invariably slide into
those uh mental thinking traps anyway
um to get started off uh we have a
question and this is something I ran in
person at when I did the talk NYU uh
what is the ratio of machine learning
code to non-ml code in your in any
application that one could think of or
in an application that one one is
intending to deploy ml so here's a QR
code for that if you guys could pull up
your phones and appointed
them and I believe you can also go to
this URL I'm not sure whether that URL
is
visible you can I sent it in SL chelo
all right and I'll give give give us all
a minute just to respond to it there are
three choices in there um yeah take your
best guess at what what you think is the
proportion of ml code to non-ml
code we'll continue on uh that that
survey is interesting to us just to see
how people react differently before and
somewhere Midway through the
conversation so typically what what does
machine learning involve what is machine
learning invol uh does machine learning
uh entail right if you ask
anyone everyone one someone would people
would most likely say pick a model all
right let's do
that and train them all right let's do
that uh and then deploy them so there's
at least we have come to a a phase in in
in contemporary conversation where we've
recognize that there are three different
faces uh and there have distinct faces
that one can one needs to go through and
you know at the end of this we would
have deployed machine learning and our
system which was uh without a machine
learning model previously now is capable
of using a machine learning model and
and we're
done so obviously uh that's not the case
uh we don't go home there's something
missing here in this
thinking and in order to emphasize that
or at least illustrate uh part of what
that is is the disconnect between what
we think typically versus what what what
is truly involv in I've laid out
something along the lines of what might
be conceived of a a typical uh
architecture of an application and down
at the bottom I have something in yellow
highlighted that is disembodied
perspective and you may see some of
these you know recur in some of the
slides uh that kind of helps drive home
some of the thinking traps so here we
have users on the way on the left
there's a web tier in the somewhere the
next to that and then we have these
microservices or the app tier bunch of
caches and cues and so on and then there
is the data storage and files far on the
right um this would be a regular stack
of application you know there are many
ways to slice and dice them there are
many different architectures of uh you
know applications uh probably people
know of MVC models and and related
families of models uh models as in uh uh
techniques of architecturing
applications but way on the side down at
the bottom uh is the ml model standing
aloof by itself on the on on the side
and this is what what I call the
disembodied perspective this is what we
generally Carry On Carry On Carry with
uh in in our in our minds and obviously
the the argument here is that that is
not the
case so let's look at how one conceives
of the flow of machine learning within a
uh within an organization in the sense
we actually spoke about the three phases
pick pick a model train the model and
deploy it and essentially here what I'm
highlighting is the is is that itself
horizontally laid out but we're
embellishing it with a few metrics down
at the bottom and saying all right I
have at the end of having created a a
model test validated it and tested it I
look at the metrics and say okay my
metrics look great now it is and here
I'm showing something known as a
classification uh area under the curve
uh and it's it's greater than 50% that
is indicative of uh this model now being
ready to be deployed into our life
system um but again let's say we did
that what typically would happen is
something along the lines of what you
see in the goal metrics on the right
hand side you may have a initial bump or
boost in in your goal metric and then
you you would see a gradual
deterioration in your goal metric over
time and especially this is quite
relevant in the in the case of um uh
online settings and online service
settings uh where what we have what is
known as contextual decisions being made
a user repeatedly interacts with the
system you go to YouTube let's say
you're shown a a video to watch and then
you interact with it choose not to watch
it or watch it and then you're um you
you're given another recommendation and
so on what would initially happen is for
the first few weeks the first few days
that you deploy a specific machine
learning model you would see a little
bit of bump in the in the goal metric
that you're looking at and then after a
week or two or so you would see a
deterioration it would just uh uh
neutral
out and then one could get a little bit
more sophisticated in one's argument and
argument and say all right we should not
have just directly deployed what we saw
was uh performing well in offline uh
into our production we should have
perhaps done an AB test all right let's
say we did do an AB test uh we do again
see would see something along the same
lines as what we saw if we deployed it
in real world which is an initial bump a
novelty effect that phases uh that goes
away in a little
while
um now one question one could argue or
one could think of is uh there is a
subtle difference here it it is not
subtle to the practitioners uh there's a
difference between the goal metric that
you're interested in and what the
objective is that that you trained your
machine learning models to the objective
that you train your machine learning
model is something like predicting am I
going to click on this advertisement or
am I going to watch this video uh the
goal metric that you're interested in is
not so much whether individuals watch
those videos or not but maybe an
aggregate that says as a overall is the
is the uh count of sessions or the the
time that people spend on our platform
increasing so there could be a little
bit of a difference between uh the
individual action versus the the goal
metric so one could ask the question why
can we not directly move the goal metric
right uh and this is why we say there's
a difference between what is commonly uh
perceived and seen from a distance
versus what is trained by the Machinery
to be
learned hopefully our hope here is that
that distance between the the metric of
interest for the team or the company or
the organization versus the objective
that the machine learning model is built
on can be bridged by adequate data
science analysis and somehow approximate
that we may have multiple uh objectives
that a machine learning model needs to
learn so that in aggregate they behave
closer to what the uh the the company's
goal metrics would be all right that is
um uh along the lines of goal metric
contributive user action just tapping
into the right kind of um objective
functions in these machine learning
models so that your ab test start
showing positive improvements that's one
possible uh remediation to that uh that
distinction
being
missed uh another item that I want to
bring out here and this is um
particularly relevant for online
services something along the lines of a
um of a social media Network or U uh or
or something along the lines of a
YouTube Right a Content uh recommended
system uh if you look in here there the
very first thing that happens is there's
an impression of an app uh uh impression
by an app onto the user's um uh device
right at that specific point there is
the decision to be made uh what
advertisement or what content is it that
I'm going to show let's say we do show
something out to the user the user has a
delayed reaction to that they may choose
to click or not click now these clicks
are obviously easily labelable in the
sense that you can you immediately see a
click and you can label them as a one
let's say but what about the no no
clicks right uh there is no distinct um
de uh identifier that tells us that this
label was this advertisement this
content was never clicked on right in
order to get that uh correctly
engineered what we typically do is uh we
enforce thresholds time thresholds that
says if the person doesn't click in 24
hours or 48 hours or so we're going to
label it to zero and so on uh but uh
that obviously leads to um biased
sampling of when bias Gathering of data
and so on because who should say whether
it should be 24 hours versus 25 hours
right um So that obviously leads to data
hygiene which also has a bearing on what
we call partial
feedback uh anyway I was just giving you
a sampling of some of the thinking traps
that we fall into now I'm just going to
give give you a slide that contains
various questions that we peripherally
spoke about previously uh one question
in here that I would like to bring our
attention to is the one that's the the
fourth one which is U features could be
null due to data service interruptions
in the sense that at the time of
gathering your training data you may
have tons of features that may look nice
and pretty in as if we we have been
given clean sane data uh sanitized data
but in real life at the time of
predicting at the time of serving we
actually encountered quite a few nulls
simply because that's the reality of uh
Services uh when you are attempting to
fetch features quite a few of them could
be null so that is that bullet point
essentially uh is to highlight the fact
that there is a gross uh complexity
misestimation in our perception of what
machine learning
entails and specifically interactive
settings where such as in online you
know uh Services where you go out and
purchase things or where you go out and
interact with social media Network or or
YouTube like content um as we previously
mentioned uh we could have partial
feedback and we also have delayed
rewards and and one thing to note about
partial feedback is let's assume that um
we are uh we are providing uh news Serv
we are providing digital news content to
viewers so a a young adult may be uh
preferentially shown uh
content about sports let's say whereas a
non- young adult might be shown as a
Content about politics now what this
leads to is that uh since we have not
sampled or shown enough of young adults
Sports I mean not Sports content but uh
news content any feedback that we get is
is biased and vice versa for the the non
young adults in the sense that we are
always not sufficiently exposing all
subs segments of users to all possible
treatments so that's uh you know just a
few uh a few seconds of blur on what
partial feedback is but in interactive
settings uh we also uh the goal there is
to essentially find the best policy that
Maps context to actions that means you
want to find the the best uh mapping of
of context in here means that uh it's a
user at a particular device at a
particular time of the day what's the
specific advert
to be shown or what's the specific
content to be
shown uh and discovering that is the
goal of an of the Machinery in an
interactive setting uh this is a little
bit different from a supervised learning
setting but uh the the essence of all
these is to uh is to recognize that um
uh there are complexities that we
misestimate uh now here having said all
these I'm going to show you a quick
pipeline of what um
what's involved in um embedding we have
taken out a bunch of uh things in here
just to show the events that uh flow
through as uh machine learning is
thought of in in a system initially
there is an impression that so this is
talking about a contemporary
application the the the content is
impressed on the device then the user
let's say performs certain things but
before the user takes specific actions
you log the features as to what the user
is where the user is where the what the
location of the user is and a tons of
other
features and then as a delayed reward
you you log the
labels all right that's the user clicked
on the ad or not and then eventually we
have collect them all together correlate
them and then off on the side although
we have shown an arrow in the off on the
side we do the training of the ml model
and then when we plug in the real ml
model into the system this is what
happens we stick the ml model up there
so that even at the time of impression
or even before impression we ask the ml
model what is the content that needs to
be shown right this is the general uh
setup that that happens
um now when I ask the question having
shown these thinking traps and uh shown
a little bit of the sketch of uh what
the flow and the events are that a
typical ml system would uh entail uh
want us to let's take a look at this
survey once again and see
uh what the responses are like if you
don't if you could enter you know uh
entertain me and uh bring up your phones
and respond this is a new survey please
yeah okay all right let's move on I
think we have comparable numbers of uh
both okay
great right now we're going to quickly
talk about a few structures and uh
perspectives that may be helpful so that
we we have a little bit more of a
a a a detailed U um idea of how how and
what machine learning entails or
introducing machine learning into
applications
and so what's one of the things we could
quickly do well we could endless bunch
of questionnaire to be asked even before
we um even before we uh take on the
burden of uh uh sticking in machine
Learning Systems into an application so
again these are this is just a a
checklist of questions one could ask uh
this is by the way a a checklist of
questions one could ask if one were to
build a um a ml system from scratch
right uh or you could you could use the
same thing to also uh apply an ml system
to an existing application so now I'm
not going to read through all of these
um uh a few things here that would be of
interest to folks would be something
along the lines of modeling right what
what kind of modeling are we doing uh
what is also of Interest which is
typically missed is uh the the last item
which is serving and monitoring how do
we serve these models and how do we
continuously update these models
right uh that's nice but where do we go
from here right so uh there's a
beautiful paper by uh Google on
this uh which is to recognize there are
a few phases uh of machine learning
deployment which is uh starts off with
before ml take a look at an application
before ML and then there's the phase
where you actually apply the first model
and then you do the subsequent ml
engineering that is perhaps a second or
third version of the model and then you
go into a later stage where you have
slowed growth and hardly any effect or
uh gains are realized unless you
actually are able to make tremendous
changes to the machine learning model
itself right um typically some of the
major wins are found in the first model
and and the the second or third models
or at least the larger milestones and
larger chunks of winds in terms of
Engagement are are to be found there
subsequently we go into a slowed growth
phase and um here uh what I want to
highlight is the fact that machine
learning is the high interest credit
card of technical debt so how many of us
know what is techn technical
debt great so uh very quickly uh it is
uh technical de debt can be summarized
as the the the uh the the cost of
suboptimal choices made during the life
cycle of a of a product development or
product
engineering and these suboptimal choices
are not made uh you know whimsically
they are made simply because they are
perhaps the most experient way to get a
product feature out or to meet a
deadline and so on uh in the case of
machine learning uh the the the the
technical debt items are much more
complicated than regular code uh uh
technical uh debt uh one item in here of
particular importance is that data
dependencies what we do what we do
essentially doing in by bringing in
machine learning is we are bringing in
data dependencies into our system so uh
the choice of whether to show the user a
red button or a red text versus a blue
button or blue text is made now by the
data so those
dependencies are actually get learned by
a machine learning system and brought
into the code uh and those dependencies
uh can change over time and not just
that it's not easy to troubleshoot and
debug them uh over the course of an
application the the third item in there
the system level spagetti has to do with
the amount of glue code that is the the
amount of machine learning supporting
code that's required to make an
application capable of using machine
learning systems uh there's a tremendous
amount of code that goes in if we use
libraries off the
shelf uh if there's one takeaway from uh
this entire talk that might be right
there the acronym CAC uh which is change
anything changes
everything uh specifically with uh
applications that are equipped with uh
machine learning models what one would
find is that uh if you change the
distribution of one particular feature
it changes or makes ineffective your
existing machine learning model and that
requ requires us to train and build a
model over again it doesn't have to be
from scratch but it requires us to uh
relearn the the the uh the uh the the
dependencies between the uh
features so now that we go into the
third part of the talk where we actually
show an example of how one can can
possibly remediate and think through
some of these straps way ahead of time
and show an engineered solution uh this
solution is based on work by
Microsoft and uh uh there are portions
of it that are applicable to what what
they call uh what we call contextual uh
decision situations which is an online
setting where you are uh on a on a on a
platform like YouTube and there is
repeated interaction either engaging or
not engaging with the content
and I think this is perhaps a more
interest than maybe a supervised
learning
setting so this is a decision service
this is a system for uh contextual
decision
making uh there is repeated interaction
of a user with a particular uh
application and the act of interacting
with that application uh changes
subsequent uh choices uh given to the
user um there are four four abstractions
here of interest uh one is explore log
learn and
deploy these abstractions are now here
we actually show how it is deployed out
these abstractions allow us to clearly
separate out various faces if you want
to call it faces of the users uh
interaction with the application so
application way out on the left left
side uh the app now has a direct
communication to explore this is the
point at which we are the or the app is
requesting the um requesting the ml
Machinery to give us a content right uh
how do we make the choice at this point
we call it explore simply because it's
not handing out uh the best choice at
that point there is a little bit of an
exploration happening in addition
perhaps to exploitation so those
familiar those of you familiar with
reinforcement learning may know that
explore exploration exploitation
contention or the the the different
motivations behind that and that happens
in that phase so a policy that handles
that uh uh hands out a response back
gives you a choice of what is it what is
the content that needs to be shown to
the specific
user um and in the act of doing that uh
although we have notated a box way down
in the bottom left hand corner as
feature generator it's all pervasive and
available across the board to all
components or all all abstractions
here uh so the question of what do I
show vickram who is on the on the app
right now what content do I show uh
requires features to be generated at
that point in time so that is a the one
way to think of that is a compression of
all the existing data that we know about
the history of this person's interaction
with the app uh and maybe more and their
location the day and time and so on and
so forth right and that compression
compressed data is available to us
feature is generated for the Machinery
to make a decision to uh for the policy
to uh give out a a particular
choice and subsequent to
that perhaps a few minutes down the line
or a few seconds down the line or a few
days down the line uh the we the system
receives a a reward from U from the app
at that point there is a correlation
between what was generated and what this
person's action was and the two are
correlated and allowed that join they
joined together which allows us to do uh
an online learning an online learning
essentially means that the machine
learning model is Le changing and
updating its weights or parameters uh
based on that one sample of interaction
that we just saw of course there are
learning rate uh deck and things of that
nature that we apply so that this one
one instance doesn't uh shift the
machine learning model much you know out
further out into uh into undesirable
territories but that's what you do and
then if we have sufficient we have
passed sufficient we have gathered
sufficient amount of data there is also
the choice of an offline learning which
eventually allows us to deploy a a newer
model into into the
system um if one way to think about
machine learning system now as fully
entrenched into your application with a
a life cycle of you know events that the
users would go through and the system
would go through then I think we have a
little bit a little bit of a more mature
uh perspective of things and then we
quickly see that
um uh the
the the the burden of uh bringing in
machine learning is not just what we
initially thought of it uh thought of as
being uh three distinct phases and of uh
you
know this is much more a little bit more
of uh engineering involved
business what are the saliencies of that
architecture that we saw first thing is
the service obstructions the service
obstructions is what makes makes it
possible for us to uh clearly delineate
them uh the the log versus the the learn
and so on and so
forth then it further uh it allows this
is the last bullet point this is a setup
like this allows us to address
non-stationarity which is the fact that
in the real world we hardly ever find
stationary data that means the
distribution of the features they change
constantly over time they're never uh
The Joint distribution is never uh the
same uh and that is addressed by virtue
of us having the online learner learn as
we see examples come
through
and some of the other know saliences can
be read through in the paper um if know
for those folks who are interested in
under the covers there are certain
things that happen to facilitate this uh
setup uh one of them is um the
exploration of the exploration policy
that's a policy that is handed out and
that's making the decision is not the
only policy that is being uh evaluated
and that's possible using inverse
propensity score estimators for policies
and so on and U I'll give you a
reference to the paper at the
end uh what does uh that uh structure
that I just showed uh me and tail in
terms of code of course this is uh I'm
trivializing this but highlighting the
fact here that these are the signatures
that one could have so there is an
object called ml apps mlops uh which uh
has specific entry points into each of
those uh faces or in each of those
abstractions you know explore log learn
deploy and so on and then in your
application that actually uses these MLS
ml systems now we get a little bit more
cleaner of a separation between um the
ml Ops versus core app uh issues or core
app logic again it's not it's not
completely separated as soon as we
introduced machine learning models into
into this application now we would see
ml uh stuff all over the code but the
the cleanliness here is in the fact that
we have injected and for those folks who
may know of dependency injection we have
injected the dependency into an object
called mlops and then we are able to
isolate our changes specific to machine
learning into those calls right there uh
without something like this typically
you would find hundreds and hundreds of
lines of if else conditions in in your
code uh uh in your machine learning code
in your application code in order to
specifically have handle conditions of
you know changing variables and
parameters and so
on um so these are the references that I
uh mentioned um if one were to take a
look at some of these uh
the and wanted to spend a little bit of
time I would highly recommend the second
one uh and for those folks who are
involved in um um in a contextual
setting which is contextual systems
design uh the third U item as well
um and that's about the stuff I wanted
to talk about uh I want to open it up
for questions for you know from
anyone When you mention A and B testing
right um what
are example of of how you do that change
what change are going to make are you
making relevant to learn something about
the machine learning model right so I
don't let me repeat the question uh when
you spoke about a andb test AB testing
right how do we make changes in an AB
testing what does that mean in Context
oh in the context of machine learning
right so uh so the question is uh what
does AB testing mean in the context of
machine learning right so let's
assume uh we developed a model that
produces promising results on
clickthrough rates right so that means
uh we are able to now predict very
accurate whether a person is able to uh
is is going to click on a particular add
or content um and offline testing showed
that you had a training data test data
and it showed what would we do in an AB
testing is segment of a a p a portion of
users call them a and a portion of users
we call them B and to a we Supply them
the original situation which is no
machine learning model let's say into
the population or the segment we call
called B we subject them to the machine
learning model so you make code changes
so that you can distinguish between the
two users so the users who use the who
see the flavor B would now see a
different behavior in terms of the
content that is recommended to them
whereas the users a would see the
traditional content that they would have
Without The Machine learning
model okay and the Machine learning
model is embedded in the in the you know
in the in the call to uh the user who
are uh who who are exposed to the the to
the path B and that's AB testing and
what we do is typically run that for a
few weeks to see whether we between the
two portions of uses do we see a
measurable dis uh difference in the
outcomes of interest for the
team and that's AB testing do you need
to reverse them in case that you have a
biased selection of users yeah that's a
good question so the question is uh do
we need to reverse the A and B to see
whether there is a you know if we have a
bias selection of A and B so the
guarantees of the the quick response to
that is we do not because the guarantees
of the systems that create AB testing
Frameworks is that these are randomly
chosen people that so the representation
of every Subs segment in a is equally
the the same in in b as well so you do
not necessarily have to do
it C yes so I I'm really glad that you
brought up the piece on um data hygiene
because I feel like that comes up like
like a lot and this is more of a
question I'm wondering if people in your
space are are um thinking about like
have you seen people trying to instead
of just modeling like classification so
instead of thinking like is it zero one
of um approaching as like a time to
event type where like your event is say
like a click and so you're thinking of
as like a sensorship situation where
it's like it's like a continuously
ongoing variable so you're kind of like
um cuz would that seem like something
that also like a stakeholder is
interested in like not just like did
somebody click on it but are they
clicking on the app like right away
versus like conditional over some longer
stretch of time right uh so the question
is uh in the line of in in contextual uh
settings in online settings rather uh we
are interested not so much in whether
the user has clicked on a on a
particular content but U uh what's the
time that someone has taken to click on
it so uh yes the short answer is yes I
have seen uh for so here I have posted
as a or or shown it as a a
classification question is it a 01 uh
there are organizations who have done
something else which is a time to an
event um and that that has you A varying
degrees of success as well um one thing
I want to mention here is that uh
specifically in online settings it's a
it's a longtail distribution so that
means uh the number of people who react
immediately versus who react after a
week or so uh would be uh it would be
disproportionate so perhaps modeling
that in one model or one SE one one
single model may not be uh that
beneficial because now the model is
attempting to predict uh one week as
well as 1 second as well as two weeks so
the the time rate the the output range
becomes so wide so typically what is
done in such scenarios is uh either you
break them down into a hierarchical
model in which you say is this person
likely to respond within a day uh or
greater so that's the first level of
hierarchy then in each one of these
hierarchies subsequently you predict the
exact number of days if you wanted to so
that's something I've seen uh with
varying success and um it's it's not a
solved problem it is still a problem
that various vendors have done uh in
approaching different ways great does
does that oh yeah absolutely I'm just
curious if you'd seen it and things like
that cuz that's that's kind of where my
might went but but super helpful
yeah please yeah sorry sorry I don't
know how many more questions you could
do but I was wondering about the uh
inverse probability scoring estimator
that you have can you kind of dive into
the under the hood uh way that you score
that the estimator yeah uh let me try to
see if I have a
slide that yeah this was a slide I
created uh specifically to possibly
attempt answering something like this so
let's say uh we so the question is uh we
want to delve into the inverse
probability scoring right uh let's say
the context is X uh the column X the
action is all those that we recommend
and then there is a probability number
and then there is a delayed reward and
the table three I show there uh is under
executing an executing policy called Pi
so let's say we are executing Pi 1 these
are the uh x a r p that we observe okay
but we are in the act of gathering this
data one might say okay we can only now
know how Pi 1 behave behaves but what
what're truly saying with with IPS is
that no that's not true we can also
evaluate a policy pi3 uh by looking at
those um context action pairs which have
matching outcome as Pi 1 so if you look
closely we have C3 a0 as the last row uh
and there is a probability P 01 and the
reward of 96 uh you can take that row
data which is what we observed and apply
that to estimate what the uh re uh the
the the the score for uh Pi 3 would be
the the of course there's mathematics to
show you that ASM totically if you if
the number of interactions as it
approaches Infinity this is an unbiased
estimator of this meaning this IPS
estimator is an unbiased estimator of Pi
3 as well okay and that's what I
attempted showing in in this algebraic
expression
here uh down the the last one right so
Pi um Pi
I uh can be evaluated uh by data that
has been collected by say policy Pi
okay does that answer your question yeah
yeah yeah please again n question when
you mentioned the BM um again for
somebody who who's looking from the
outside looking in um if you run a model
or something you would think things will
get better you seem to the performance
seems to decrease how does that explain
yeah uh so the question is uh uh looking
from the outside one might assume that
uh deploying a model would improve the
uh the outcome of interest you know
something along the lines of daily
active uses for example but uh how do we
explain deteriorating or maybe even
neutral uh
outcomes so there are um that's a very
uh deep question it's not a naive
question in the sense that that is
essentially why we all these organiz
have tons hundreds and hundreds of
Engineers look at things like these uh a
few uh quick pointers on what may be
causing these uh not what what causes
these is that U the the act of
recommending something changes the
distribution of the the input that we
subsequently
see uh so when you deploy a machine
learning model and let's say uh we are
interested in sports videos or uh and
then more and more Sports videos arrive
on our Appliance our device um our
Behavior changes so we change as a
consequence of the the recommendations
now uh you know adhering more and more
to our likes cuz we may be more
discriminatory now and see I only like
videos of this particular player or
something and again I'm trivializing
that that's one thing uh the other thing
is that um and the user Behavior changes
so this uh and this is related also to
the fact also to that fact that uh the
data is
non-stationary the distributions that we
saw in a model at the time the model was
deployed is not the distribution a week
later the distribution of features a
week earlier but when the model was
deployed is not the distribution of
features a week later after the model is
deployed so that's why in that uh
decision service that I showed you there
was a explicit online learning block
that attempted to address this which is
to say that every interaction even a
single interaction is possibly able to
contribute something to the learning
constantly through online learning
mechanism now if you randomize your
recommendations would that
help you know lessen the
impact if so the question is if we
randomize the the the recommendations by
the machine learning models would it
lessen the well if we randomize the the
out the machine learning
model predictions or or outcomes subset
or something right well we you are then
exploring this particular Subspace right
we would not be able to know
specifically in the sense what are the
ones to be uh you know uh to be handed
out as recommendations see random would
actually correspond to tossing a coin
right 50% chance you would assume right
um but I I
if you say it randomized within a subset
I do not know in a I think the the books
I get recommendation for books and if
the recommendations were more
unusual that might Pike my interest to
to explore that if they were like more
repeated right or more more common like
right so uh something along the lines of
within a a genre you may have there are
models that there are people there
machine learning models that people have
explored something along the lines of a
a gaussian model right gaussian mixture
model where you you are you are now
identified as a member of
this of member of this section of users
who like a particular genre and now we
can sample from that genre and then
recommend yeah they they may help in
that setting yes um yeah but it's it's a
it's a deep question it's a it's a
there's no single answer to that
question in my thinking please so um
during the presentation you emphasized
the um the importance of kpis metrics
and things related to that right uh now
that language models are more popular
than ever have you experienced any kind
of evaluation of metrics when the output
is an actual like new text and not like
a categorical or numeric uh output right
so uh the question is uh now that
as opposed to what we showed which is uh
a prediction
01 if what if the language what if we're
looking at language
models um do I have any experience uh
with uh the the quality of language
model I personally do not have an
experience with that um uh but I from
what I read and what I what I gather
um there is a a specific phase of large
language model training called rlf or
reinforcement learning based on human
feedback and that is precisely
attempting to do something along these
lines which is um aligning the machine
the the llm outcome output to be more in
line with what human beings have
previously chosen to be preferential a
versus B know they given choices and
then the Machinery is now CES to produce
more of what humans have labeled as
being more preferred
um I do not know whether that answers
your question yeah yeah I mean still
being a human layer process right right
and and I think there are there are some
organizations which have tried doing
that as well as using another Machinery
so you could use a second llm to do
something like that things like that
yeah thank
you using like a classification like
like you were using like label data like
01 for as your outcome how do you um
collect those label data or how do you
make sure your label dat
is correct at the first place to
training at training right uh how do we
so the question is let's say we have a
classification setting and we have data
that is labeled zero and one how do we
really know that the labels zero really
represents zero and one really
represents one or how do we collect
those how do we collect right
um
so
uh of course there is a um there is
noise in all these data that we collect
for sure right but um if you look at
contextual decision settings usually
it's based on events that we have
gathered like like I said the user has
clicked on an ad uh click user has you
know engaged with a video you know
things of that nature there is an a user
event that is traceable to that
particular uh context so I think I
showed that in one of the slides here
something along the lines of fall
uh the second bullet point so we are
somehow able to correlate the x that is
the context and the a the action that
was prescribed recommended what was the
reward what is in this case a one or a
zero label and what is the probability
of the of that action originally being
recommended uh so uh maybe not your
question is not pertinent to this but
typically the assumption is that we have
a reliable way of gathering the data uh
in the Machinery that we have built and
you're right uh it is conceivable that
if we look
at something
like here since because we have delayed
uh response and reward and so on um it
is quite likely that we may be not be
gathering uh unbiased and uh uh hygienic
data that's possible yeah but the best
we can do is build Machinery to be able
to gather them so uh in the deploy
actually the last uh the Microsoft
architecture yeah that that one yeah so
there was offline learning as well as
online learning right so how do we tie
those two down together right the
result when we are when we're about to
make a decision that's a good question
so uh the question is uh here in the in
the in here we in the learn fa
abstraction we show two of them there's
an online learner and there's an offline
learner right how do we tie the two of
them typically this is done an offline
learner is learning off of um weeks data
weeks and weeks worth of data or maybe
in months worth of data um
and how the online learner is learning
based on every interaction right or
maybe a sampling from every you know
from a from that interaction that
happens in real life um the ideally you
do do want to have some Metric to
compare the between the two of them
before you choose to say this is the one
I'm going to store and deploy
subsequently so there has to be some
some regime under which that happens and
that regime would invol okay what is the
what is the frequency and Cadence at
which you would do that and so on and so
forth right so there is no uh one point
specific you know answer to that except
that you you go through the the action
of uh comparing the outcome metric for
both these
models okay yeah does that get to
okay yes please just pleas in the future
we're curious about the recommendation
system would you say that one is that is
one of your like main topics of
expertise yeah okay so it's about my
personal experence yeah so yeah I think
I've worked quite a bit with
recommendation systems and ranking
systems here nice all right great thank
you everybody thank you
[Applause]
all
so the results of the survey let me pull
up my phone cuz I saved them there and
they are going to
be so the first survey the pre-o survey
60% of the people said less than
5% 24% said 5 to 20 and 16 said 20 to
60 the second time around it was 50 27
23 so shifted around a little bit yes it
did um uh so what I observed at at at
NYU where I gave this talk previously
was uh uh it was almost
bipolar Trend after the fact a lot of
people went like almost 50% went to
under 5% Cod is ML and the rest of the
folks went to uh around 60% is ml code
uh the the the the question was uh U put
out there just so uh to gauge what
people perceived walking in so so in a
realist realistic system the amount
number of lines of code at a pure ml is
typically less than 5% what is what
makes the bulk of it is the glue code
the supporting code that uh helps
bolster the whole thing up and that
includes libraries that do all sorts of
data Transformations and you know
feature engineering and so on in terms
of differences between a well-designed
setup and a one which is full of
technical debt right what how do those
percentages
work
I
mean I think well-designed systems even
those if you look at it very closely
have does not have the machine learning
amount machine learning related code is
very little in comparison to the the
engineering that requires to feed it the
data and so on so and again I do not
can't speak for the first category that
you spoke of
though all right thank you thank you
very much for the talk little round of
applause the 10th anniversary of the New
York R conference once they go on sale
tickets are available n rats. a and and
use code NY hackr for 20% discount
because you're members of this Meetup we
need a speaker for next month anyone has
been inspired to give a talk at the next
month's Meetup come find me I'm here now
I'll be at the bar um otherwise look out
for an email when we're going to
announce it and have a great night